bonjour c'est vrai il ya
quelques jours va proposer des
lecteurs du vélib' à paris
droits réservés certes coupe
pour un oiselet et les autres de
par le globe
une policière
moi je suis pas adepte du
vélib' jusqu'à ce que je tombe
sur cette vidéo
le canada car la leaf d'affaires
2008 en recul mais je me suis
même motif neuf ans
on ne peut pas encore tirer un
trait sur l'appareil se faire
sentir d'abonnement
vous êtes durée d'abonnement
validez les conditions
d'utilisation les 150 euros de
caution de plus le fait de sa
carte bleue j'espère que nous
pourrons retirer son vélo
validez le cas de prendre son
ticket en fait sur le retrait
d'un hélicoptère et d'une grue
pour retirer son équipe
présidée par sms passés de
cet assassinat
c'est pour moi une énigme
apprentissage à la peine
handball d2m sms aidés par
l'état en tentant d'utiliser
cette manipulation de l'homme
moderne
la piste cyclable qui je le
rappelle est utilisé par deux
types de personnes d'abord les
cyclistes
et les gens qui marchent dessus
de manchester est toujours en
dedans au troisième échelon
qui ne marchent plus et pourtant
c'est fait invité par aaa quoi
pensent les gens quand ils se
promènent sur la piste cyclable
elle est sympa cette petite
année la personne dessus
les gens sont cons marche à
côté
car c'est quoi ce logo
on dirait une piste
il n'y a pas que les piétons
que tu prends sur la piste
cyclable ainsi les les voitures
mal garées et sauvage traverser
les autres cyclistes qui roulent
en sens inverse de celle des
sens
sur les plus efficaces a
indiqué le porte-parole après
avoir enseigné à ce moment-là
elle est sympa cette piste
cyclable
la psychose
ils ont fait un cycliste a
ouvert
qui sont connus
on peut donc aller vite
mais quand tu prends pas des
piétons
dans des voitures ou d'autres
sites distants la guerre
quand tu pense pas encore être
en sécurité
c'est la ville qui commence à
faire peur à un moment j'ai dû
utiliser une piste que je vous
jure qu'il va s'étendre
la voix des voitures
et la voie pour les bus
c'est-à-dire l'endroit le plus
dangereux du monde le médicis
essai a été testé les six
fois que télégénique et quand
on sait que vous n'êtes plus il
ya de meilleur pour la fin
prend trop de buts
et les voitures comme ça qu'on
s'est bien au-dessus du niveau
de vie des moteurs sur la gauche
il faut écraser par un bus
à
avec beaucoup de talent je suis
toujours en vie les gens avec
qui j'ai vécu
lisez aussi perdre
si vous faites du vélo
avec un effectif amoindri que
vous
petit conseil
mettez-vous derrière
ce soir
le plus généreux
continuez à revoir ma page
facebook vous êtes de plus en
plus nombreux même si je sais
que la moitié des chansons des
faux profils créés par la mer
de saint-pierre par exemple
on continue cela dépendant des
élections locales pour
coordonner leurs efforts d'aidé
aux employés de la soirée
après une longue journée des
villes les plus élevés au
canada